the raiders have their biggest game
of the season that big game coming up
this weekend the chiefs are in town and
ron futrell has the very latest on the
betting line for the game
so we're ripping right along through
this nfl season we'll talk about the
raiders and chiefs in just a moment but
how about those new york jets
they're 0 and 9 right now this has to be
like one of the longest seasons ever for
them
and they're two and seven against the
spread so the bettors
have been making some money going
against them it's an automatic play we
need the jets every week which
is kind of tough sitting back there and
watching you know like you said they are
not
very good against the spread this year
so they're on
almost everybody's parlay and every week
there's money against the jets and
why not it's worked out well for the
bettors so now we have the raiders
against the defending super bowl
champion
chiefs raiders won at kansas city
already this year
40-32 they hope to pull off another
upset this weekend
it's kind of a hard game to figure out
with all the covet issues that we've got
here so we did open the game seven that
did go to eight and uh
mostly that's the information on the
cove it seemed like the raiders have
more players with the covert than the
chiefs at
this point so it's been quite quiet
as far as the betting on that game and
so hopefully we will get through the
on the game and have this sunday night
game here so the biggest matchup of the
season for both the raiders and the
chiefs takes place here
at allegion stadium on sunday the winner
of this matchup will control the afc
west
at allegiant stadium i'm ron futuro
reporting 8 sports now